[Music]
flying is always fun but if you end up
bringing the wrong object to the airport
you could put yourself and the entire
plane in danger did you know that snow
globes are forbidden on planes
stay tuned to find out why don't forget
to subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out 10 strangest things not allowed on
airplanes printer cartridge say what
that you didn't know that in 2010 there
was a huge uproar when TSA banned ink
and toner cartridges from carry-ons
if your printer cartridge has more than
16 ounces it'll be banned from inbound
and inner u.s. flights so if you have a
specific printer there's a good chance
that you won't be able to bring the
cartridges with you the reason for this
is actually quite surprising but it does
make sense it turns out that back in
2010 there were several cases of
explosives being planted in the
cartridges seems a bit absurd but on
October 29th 2010 two packages of these
cartridges were found on two separate
cargo planes the cartridges were
fortunately safely discovered at enroute
stopovers which triggered the ink and
toner cartridges ban luckily no one was
hurt but this fan just makes sure no one
else will get hurt either but it's
pretty strange to think that even if you
buy a printer abroad there's a good
chance you won't be able to carry
cartridges especially if you fly within
or to the u.s. who would have ever
thought that an ink cartridge could be
this dangerous or use it in such a
harmful way walkie-talkies if you ever
look at the rules of which items you're
allowed to bring on the airplane you
probably never notice that
walkie-talkies are frequently mentioned
it doesn't matter if you have the toy
walkie-talkies or something made for
adults unless you're the pilot you
absolutely can't bring or use
walkie-talkies on board with you the
reason for that is actually pretty
simple walkie-talkies are operated by
radio satellites and talking to your
buddy while in the air could interfere
with satellite connection meant to be
received by the airplane pilots in the
air traffic control this could mean the
pilot might miss important pieces of
information that could put the entire
plane in danger interestingly not a lot
of people know about this ban a Reddit
user called spotlight master asked if
there was a chance that we communicate
with a group of friends on another claim
of course the answer is no in 2016
American man was spotted with a
walkie-talkie at an Indian Airport he
was interrogated by the police but
pleaded not guilty because he wasn't
aware of this ban some walkie-talkies
actually operate on high frequencies
that could easily capture wireless
messages between the police and the
Defense Forces as well as messages sent
by the air traffic control remote
control cars back in 2007 airport
screeners became really strict when it
comes to remote control cars
remote-controlled toys in general are
forbidden and carry-ons which makes us
wonder how to fill a view from home
alone 3 bring that remote-control car on
the plane without even checking it in it
seems that this would be pretty much
impossible to do now airlines like TAF
airport Racal have a strict policy
against remote control toys but why is
it that you can't bring a toy like that
in your carry-on 2007 was the year when
this rule was enforced after was noted
that remote control toys can be used as
detonators authorities responded to a
video of two students that seemed to
have demonstrated how this would have
worked in real life in order to help
people in arab countries to fight but
the video alerted the airlines who made
sure that people with remote control
toys would go through even longer checks
this threat was proven to be real after
many incidents of remote-controlled cars
disguised as explosive devices were
attempted to be used around the world
this rule is followed by thoroughly
checking other electronics that could be
easily masked as something dangerous if
you want to buy your child a
remote-control car and bring it on a
plane get ready for the pat downs bear
repellent tsa strictly prohibits bear
repellents in both your carry-on and
checked luggage it might seem like a
strange object to carry anyways but
depending where you're from it might
seem like a good idea to bring a bear
repellent well it's not a good idea
in fact most bear repellents are
prohibited we say most because the rule
states that you're allowed to have it if
its chemical makeup is not over 2
percent of active ingredients but most
bear repellents exceed this amount tsa
which sometimes posts about the weird
things they confiscate on their
Instagram noting that a passenger tried
to fly with 8 ounces of bear repellent
in a carry-on bag unfortunately that's
not allowed fair sprays might be
inexpensive but they're definitely not
something you should put in your
carry-on the same goes for pepper sprays
and anything that could be potentially
used as
weapon while you're in the air sure you
might not actually mean any harm but the
bear spray could fall into the hands of
someone who does so unless your bear
repellent sticks to the TSA guidelines
you'll unfortunately have to leave it at
home unless you want to get in trouble
at the airports a secret ninja book
seriously if you're not following TSA on
Instagram you definitely should because
they give pretty detailed descriptions
of why something was confiscated and
usually those items are pretty crazy you
think people would think these things
through but apparently that's not always
the case for example one passenger
wanted to fly with a secret ninja book
the book seemed to be about ninjas and
training but if you open it up to the
right page you'd actually notice it's
carved in yep this passenger wanted to
fly with an indica the secret
compartment maybe they didn't mean any
harm with it and it was supposed to be
just a nice present but it's still
pretty creepy we can't even imagine what
the TSA were thinking when they scanned
a book and noticed something strange
inside it did the passenger actually
look like a ninja we're also interested
where we can sign up for this ninja and
training course because it actually
sounds pretty awesome we promise we
won't be taking our secret books on a
plane either way this was a pretty good
catch and you have to admit that TSA
often stays on top of things when it
comes to spotting some pretty bizarre
items grenade shaped objects did you
know that vaping devices are actually
allowed on the plane depending on the
airline and airport that is unless the
vaping device is in the shape of a
grenade or another explosive device we
all think it's cool to have a keychain
in the shape of a dangerous item but all
those things would be quickly
confiscated at the airport and there's
no chance we'd be able to fly with them
you'd be surprised how many times this
actually happens according to the TSA it
seems that people try to be cool but
forget that the airport is the last
place where you can pull this off to be
honest this looks scarily real and we
bet it gave the TSA a heart attack or
two after first scanning it what would
you do if you checked a bag and found an
object looking like an explosive we're
pretty sure the person who owned the bag
got in a lot of trouble and it was
really embarrassing when they had to
reveal that it was actually a vaping
device always remember never carry
objects that might look like weapons
because it usually won't work out well
at the security desk batarangs
imagine you're Batman and you want to
fly on a plane with your batarangs well
you won't be able to in case you're
confused
Batarang is a Batman shaped object that
might look super cool and an awesome
defense weapon these items are becoming
extremely common because let's be honest
they just look really cool but because
it looks so sharp and it's meant to be
thrown at people it unfortunately isn't
allowed in your carry-on it seems like a
standard rule right
well if you go through TSA s Instagram
you'll be surprised by just how many
batarangs they confiscate while it might
seem cool to bring batarangs as a
present you might want to pack them in
your checked baggage and make sure that
the place you're traveling to allows
batarangs in the first place a TSA
spokesman said that these sharp objects
have to be placed in checked baggage
where you can't reach them he also added
that this is where you should put your
bats all your collapsible bat sword and
other utility belt items
sounds like the TSA isn't a fan of
Batman but we can definitely understand
why batarangs can easily be thrown and
used as a weapon so it's better to be
safe than sorry
Samsung Galaxy Note 7 this is by far one
of these strangest objects that has ever
been banned by the TSA but it's the one
most people are familiar with back in
2016 the mobile company Samsung came
under fire
quite literally many of the Samsung
Galaxy Note 7 phones seem to have
exploded in people's hands due to bad
case design and as well as low quality
batteries this also meant that having
those phones in the air would be
extremely risky
so TSA had to take matters in their own
hands shortly after the first claims of
such incidents Samsung received almost
100 notices of battery's overheating and
causing burns as well as property damage
a Southwest flight even had to be
canceled after the smartphone exploded
during boring as a passenger was
shutting it off
just imagine the chaos it caused
according to the passenger he even
replaced the phone after the first
incident of exploding batteries were
discovered but it seems that nothing was
really done upon repair because of the
serious threats TSA decided to
completely ban the phone from the plane
must have been a pretty confusing time
for a frequent traveler fidget spinners
okay it's not all fidget spinners but
because fidget spinners became popular a
lot of people tried to experiment with
cool designs this small spinning object
was originally suppose
to be used to calm anxiety and help a
person focus but because it became an
incredibly trendy item during 2016
you could also spot some of the coolest
fidget spinners around but unfortunately
unless the object is extremely blunt you
won't be able to bring it on the plane
tsa actually confiscated plenty of
fidget spinners with razor-sharp edges
while they might be cool in any
different setting they can easily be
used as a harmful device on a plane and
put everyone's lives in danger
people have joked that fidget spinners
are new weapons of mass distraction but
things could actually get really serious
if your fidget spinner design is just
too cool for school if you still use
these toys for your anxiety it's always
best to stick to the regular design
instead of purchasing that razor sharp
upgrade especially if you know you'll be
flying with it because you might just
have to leave it behind no matter how
special or cool its design actually is
no globes imagine coming home from a
Christmas trip and bringing carefully
wrapped ornaments and decorations like
mesmerizing snow globes thinking how
much your kids will enjoy them well you
better think twice because you won't be
able to get them through one of the
weirdest things that are actually banned
by the TSA are without a doubt snow
globes that go over a specific size why
how could a cute little Christmas
ornament cause trouble on a plane
according to the TSA snow globes and
similar Christmas decorations regardless
of size or amount of liquid inside can
be forbidden on certain airlines
especially if they appear to be larger
than a tennis ball
this rule keeps on changing however TSA
is very clear about the size a snow
globe could easily be used as a weapon
considering its size as it comes with
plenty of glass it could cause
significant damage if you think about it
most snow globes are in fact larger than
tennis balls which pretty much means
you'll never be able to get them through
so if you're flying home for Christmas
make sure that your snow globe is
incredibly tiny or that it can fit in
your checked luggage because if not you
might just have to leave it at the
airport
and that's all for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]